new federal data show consumer prices
soared over the last year gas prices are
up nearly 50 percent used car prices
jumped 37 percent and prices of all
types of groceries also went up shoppers
are also finding empty shelves at stores
which is reminiscent of the early days
of the pandemic scott mcfarland has the
story
up and down the aisles of this whole
foods outside san francisco a lot of
produce was just out
like the green onions gone like
the apples i was looking for weren't
there to this shop right in new jersey
some of the water was missing last time
some of the cereals were missing
shoppers across the country are being
met with empty shelves this is actually
the third store i've been to tonight
trying to find some pasta and sticker
shock prices are off the charts off the
charts for a middle class family to eat
last month it was five dollars half a
gallon orange juice
this month
ten dollars
for a half a gallon but only one type a
new report from the bureau of labor
statistics found the price of ground
beef jumped 13 over the last year fresh
fruits nearly 8 percent eggs 11 percent
in addition to the sticker shock
shoppers across the country are
complaining of supply chain shortages
sharing images on social media of empty
shelves at grocery stores experts say
the shortage is a perfect storm severe
winter weather mixed with supply chain
issues and a rise in covet cases keeping
workers out sick amid ongoing staffing
shortages
the nation's truckers tell cbs news
they're operating with 80 000 fewer
drivers than needed
this problem with some empty shelves in
some stores is that going away anytime
soon well it's gonna it's gonna be
several weeks before we see relief doug
baker is with the food industry
association that works with grocery
stores according to his group consumer
demand for groceries jumped 50 percent
at the start of the pandemic and has not
slowed as many people continue to cook
and eat most meals at home their recent
survey found about half of shoppers say
they've noticed some products not
available at their grocery stores it's
sort of like playing whack-a-mole
so if you don't see it today you'll
probably see it tomorrow so we don't
really know what the next
local item shortage is going to be yeah
we unfortunately we don't typically know
until it's upon us
whether or not your grocery store has
some empty shelves also depends on
severe weather and the level of covert
cases in your community as the omicron
variant hopefully peaks and recedes in
the coming weeks
staffing levels will improve and
hopefully the shelves will be better
stocked
tony
boy scott i don't know what's worse the
empty shelves are the higher prices i
mean those those percentages equate to
hundreds of dollars a year maybe even
thousands for the typical family thank
you we know we'll stay on it